weekdays at nine
[Music]
big news is basketball now the aces
begin their playoff journey on wednesday
from the events center at mandalay bay
on top of being the wnba's number one
seed going in there's a little extra
motivation when it comes to taking on
phoenix logan river has that story
the ace is prepared for game one with a
number of expectations but that's just
what comes with being a top seed lost in
all of this but not forgotten is the
fact that this mercury team
bounced vegas from the playoffs last
season that's easy to look past because
in their three matchups this season the
aces have outscored phoenix by 52 points
none of the games even decided by single
digits but still asia wilson remembers
that feeling of walking off the court
last season eliminated and she's itching
to get that taste out of her mouth and
onto a title run in an unforgettable
game
for sure it doesn't leave my mind at all
i mean i look on the court today and i
can still pinpoint the last game like
it's nothing it's those things that are
forever burned into my brain and i don't
mind it at all because at the end of the
day it's kind of a situation where i'm
like okay how can i be better than last
year and how can i not let that happen
again as for wilson's open invite to the
governor the president all the house
members basically everybody with a pulse
for game one she said with a smile they
haven't hit my line back yet from
mandalay bay logan river 8 news now
all right hey tickets are on sale right
now they range in price from 17 to 121
dollars that includes fees this might be
the best bargain on the strip tomorrow
night you can find those tickets on axis
and through the aces website first round
is the best of three the semis and
championship rounds are best of five
las vegas just has to win eight games to
bring home that title hey they needed
three wins in 2020 to win the tunnel but
they got swept by seattle three games